hello everyone my name is david danko i
am the director of bioinformatics and
software engineering at biosha and today
i'm going to be talking about how we can
use molecular surveillance to better
understand our cities and better plan
public health responses using molecular
data and microbial sequencing
so
i always like to
talk about a bit of context a bit of
historical context whenever i think
about microbiology because up until
fairly recently really just the last 20
or 30 years
most microbiology was done with a set of
toolkits that would sort of surprise a
modern day of biologist training today
and that was largely just a microscope
and a culture toolkit and how this would
go many people are of course familiar
with this workflow is that you would
take your sample be it a single micro be
it a microbiome a collection of microbes
anything like that you would plate it on
a particular culture plate and then you
would perform some qualitative acids on
that culture you would perceive some
functional assays you would basically
look at this under a microscope and you
would see what was there and this kind
of approach yielded
a wealth of knowledge really about
microbes it was really incredible how
much data this can pull out it told us
about taxonomy it taught us about the
basic functions of microbes their
structures how they were organized into
groups some of their cooperative
potential um but the downside of it of
course is that it's a very
labor-intensive approach to do anything
with microbes particularly once you're
getting into microbiomes largely of
communities it's very very hard to get
high throughput
large-scale data out of this and of
course also there are all the problems
that certain microbes are very difficult
to culture
which somewhat biases the results but
nonetheless we got a fantastic amount of
information out of this
and this is sort of the fundamental root
of microbiology but
this has maybe changed and adapted in
the last 20 30 years or so and that's of
course with the rise of sequencing of
why that adaptation why that change has
happened um there is of course the
famous law uh slide that virtually every
bioinformatics presentation ever has had
that shows that the cost of sequencing
the cost of dna sequencing has decreased
exponentially faster than moore's law
and while that's certainly true and
while the massive decrease in the cost
of sequencing has been an important part
of the rise of sequencing for
microbiology and the rise of
metagenomics it's also the case that the
actual drop in moore's law has also
enabled the rise of sequencing as an
assay as a useful tool for microbiology
because with the decreasing cost of
computation with the dramatically
decreasing cost of sequencing
we can now
sequence and process vastly more data
than whatever impossible before the
point that we can understand these
communities with very very low abundance
organisms very small stuff that requires
very deep sequencing to get to
uh using just molecular data
and of course as part of this also the
third factor that allows this rise of
sequencing is the vast increase in
number of reference genomes this itself
is of course due to the rise of
sequencing but it kind of has a
bootstrapping a positive virtuous cycle
effect where the more sequencing we have
the more compute we have the more
genomes we have the better results we
can get and the more useful sequencing
is to microbiology
the workflow for this kind of sequencing
is also uh fairly well known i think to
most people here you basically you take
your microbes you can take your
microbiome you pull dna out of that
microbiome and you align that dna to
known reference genomes and once you
align that nitrogen represents you can
get some idea of what's in your sample
what the functional genes might be there
and what the taxonomy phylogeny makeup
of your sample is
and this is you know critically
important massive insights have already
been found with the microbiome lots of
interesting stuff but the one insight i
want to focus on right now that i think
is particularly important maybe often
under appreciated
is that
there really isn't such a thing as a
microbiome anymore that we're seeing
molecular there's no point there's no
scale there's no size where you can draw
a really bright line
between what is a microbe and what is a
macro there are
life forms or you know debatably life
forms in the case of primes and viruses
that exist at virtually every single
scale we can think of down to just a
little bigger than a carbon atom
all the way up to the largest known
organisms in blue whales elephants that
sort of thing and there's no point where
you can draw a bright line and say like
well this is too small to be considered
a
microbe this is too big to be considered
a
microbe
there's really a continuum here and when
we use a molecular assay like sequencing
and metagenomics to understand this we
get all of this at once we can find dna
from virtually every kingdom every order
every domain every part of this size
spectrum all at the same time and we can
use that
to better understand the world and
better understand the interactions
between the really big things and the
really small things
and how all that scales up
analogously also we can
kind of arrange this in sort of a food
pyramid idea this idea of using
molecular techniques to understand
sequencing data because we have the
things that we want to understand at the
bottom and these are big things these
are things like ecologies human health
organisms
medicine these are just these are things
we want to understand
and we can begin to look at these from a
perspective of
how they're built out of biological
molecules biological genes so that would
be genes viruses pathogens things that
let us transfect it
certainly things like um
antimicrobials are a great example here
because these are produced by genes and
genes clusters and microbes typically
but then you can also break those gene
clusters down into individual genes
individual operons or let those
individual operons become individual
sequences that produce parts of proteins
or full proteins codons in the
nucleotides all the way down so you get
many different scales and what we're
really trying to do here
is understand
this large scale of life this large
diversity in the size of life that we're
dealing with with also a large diversity
in the scale of molecules so we're both
scaling in the size of organisms we're
dealing with and we're scaling in the
size of molecules that we're using to
understand these organisms
and
my work in particular has focused a lot
on how we can understand
one particular and one really big
ecosystem which is the ecosystem and the
microbiome of cities and urban
environments so
uh for about five years i've been
working with metasub and metasub is the
metagenomics of subways and urban
violence consortium
um the names may be a little bit
antiquated from our early work because
we now do more than just metagenomics we
do culturing experiments we do tran meta
transcriptomics
uh we do even a little bit of mass
spectrometry that sort of thing but
basically we're trying to understand
microbiomes via the meta genome and
we're just trying to understand those in
cities and in particular mass transit
systems in cities uh not just subways
anymore we do buses we do any kind of
mass transit system that's out there but
it started with studying the subways
particularly in new york city so
medisub is is this big global consortium
uh we have about 60 70 cities right now
and every year we have just an army a
small army of like a thousand volunteers
go out across all these cities and they
take samples from just anything in this
urban environment they can find
the only real criteria these samplers
are given is that we want them to look
for things that
appear to be abiotic so we're looking at
things that are like um
park benches metal hand railings um
concrete sidewalks that sort of thing
we're typically asking these volunteers
not to go sample for example like a
puddle or
you know the the friendly neighborhood
rat that they found or something so
we're looking at largely abiotic
surfaces and we ask these volunteers to
sample things and we have a collection
of about 5000 or so sequence samples
right now um mostly samples are
collected from 2016-2017
uh have in sequence of paradigm with 50
sequencing and that's largely what i'm
going to be talking about for the
results today because
one of the most striking things we find
in this data
is
this rather abstract plot of species
prevalent so species prevalence is the
fraction of samples where a given
species is found
and what this plot is showing is the
number of species that are found with a
given prevalence
what's not
terribly surprising about this plot is
the big spike on the left side of the
plot what is labeled the peripheral
microbiome the peripheral urban
microbiome on this plot
which consists of species that are found
in less than 25 samples there are a lot
of these species that are found in only
a small fraction of samples and this is
sort of expected um this makes sense
that there would be a lot of diversity
in these necrons
what is surprising here and what i think
is sort of critically important and
interesting to medicine's work is this
bump on the right side actually what we
term the core or the subcore
urban microbiome
because this says that there's a set of
species much more than you would expect
by random chance in random sort but
there's a set of species that are found
in virtually every single microbiome
urban microbiome sample we're looking at
in particular there's a set of about 61
species that we find in 95
of our samples
and that includes samples from cities
all over the world um
sampled different times across different
years and yet we still have this core
set of species
and what is striking about that core set
of species when you break them down into
their groups is that they're one clearly
phylogenetically organized they come
from three different phyla accident
bacteria from acuitys and proteobacteria
notably you don't see the bacteroidetes
in this there's there's no core
micromethod bacteroidetes notably lc you
don't see any viruses or fungi
that show up in this corbin microbond
there are some in the sub core uh
sacramento bca is of course in the is
the core that's pretty common it just
doesn't quite make the cutoff for a core
microbe
um but these are phytogenically
organized in the three phyla
um and what's
possibly the most interesting feature
here in my opinion is that
the majority of these taxes the majority
of these core taxes are found in 95 of
samples are not human commensal taxa
which is weird because the only thing
that you can really say about cities
definitively
uh the only thing that's common across
all cities everywhere in the world that
there are no exceptions to is that
humans live in these cities so the only
thing that we really expect to be
driving the similarity between cities is
the fact that there are humans in these
cities and we would expect human
commensals to maybe found every sample
but we find that the majority of our
core microbes are not typically
considered human conventional species
not to say they're never found in humans
just so they're not typically considered
human commensal species which gives us
this kind of striking pattern that we
can't quite explain why this is the case
yet but gives us a striking pattern
of a non-human ecosystem that we believe
is interacting and probably viable
and performing interesting functions in
the urban space
now
the fact that this core microbiome
exists is not to distract from the fact
that there are indeed continental
differences between different samples
so we have a
fairly large continental divergence that
you can see when we plot all of these
samples out of umap all of the taxonomic
profiles for the samples on the umap
and net tax and that geographic
difference largely separates east asian
samples of samples primarily from hong
kong japan
um
korea taiwan
um largely separates these samples from
samples taken from europe and north
america
um and we see a fairly big continent but
we also see smaller clusters that
correspond to sub-saharan africa to uh
to oceania to the middle east and these
clusters are mainly smaller modus things
only because we don't have as many
samples from this region our expectation
is that we add samples from this region
these clusters will become larger and
we'll start to see more clear
continental divergence between all of
these regions
and that speaks to maybe some
interesting identifiable trends and
that's a concept that when we were
researching this when we did this
research we wanted to push a little bit
farther
because what we found is not just that
there is a core
urban microbiome
that is conserved across a large subset
of samples
but that there also appear to be
certain signatures that encode certain
properties of the cities from where a
microbe is taken
that are also
conserved across the world and what i
mean by that uh specifically is that we
can find a certain set of microbes that
will reliably indicate
whether a sample was taken from a city
on the coast
from a city that has high population
from a city that has a warm climate or
cold climate
and how that works basically is we
trained a random forest model to predict
uh a city's population climate whatever
you you would like really whatever you
can see on this plot here we trained a
random forest model to predict this from
uh all of our data except for the data
from one city and then we asked the
model to predict
the uh labels for the held out city we
asked to predict the climate the
population
for samples in the held out city and we
were able to do far far better than
random when we did something like that
and what that tells us is there's some
kind of geographically con sorry
globally conserved signature that
indicates these features of a city
which we find to be really surprising
really interesting
and completely unexplainable at this
point
because
when we looked into some of these some
of these are sort of abstract concepts
it's hard to say what microbes might be
associated with population for example
when we looked into this data
we thought that we would be able to
explain
some of these features really well in
particular we thought that we would be
able to explain what microbes were
associated with coastal cities really
really easily because we thought they
were going to be halophilic microbes we
thought they were they were going to be
ocean loving microbes we thought that
they were going to be stuff that's found
in water normally makes sense that would
be associated with the coast
it wasn't what we found though not at
all um what we found is that of the sort
of top 20 most associated microbes with
coastal cities
they were not
except for two of them associated with
water at all and any documented evidence
that we could find so at this point our
ability to explain why these signatures
exist why they contain the species they
contain is very very limited and this is
one of the main ongoing areas of
research here is understanding why these
signatures exist and how they have a
mechanistic effect
on their environment and how the
environment mechanistically affects them
and with that kind of unknown sense i
want to then touch on the the most
important piece of unknown data here
which is the fact that
most of the dna in these samples can't
even be identified so the red bars here
represent sequences that are aligned to
anything in a genome at 80 average
nucleotide identity across all of our
samples
so
what we see is that almost 50 of our
data
cannot be aligned to any sequence in a
known reference database at 80 average
nucleotide identity and you know for the
the other bio partitions out there
that's using blast should be able to
pick it up with that that percent
identity
and what that tells us is that
there is a great deal of unknown dna
that comes from likely unknown or poorly
characterized clades with
new and novel genes that are out there
in these urban microbiomes that are
floating around us every single day but
that we know very very little about
and some of that surprisingly even comes
from fairly well characterized regions
like europe and north america that we
might expect to have less often still
have a very very high proportion of
unknown dna
and now
i want to
sort of switch gears a little bit
because what i've been talking about the
research we've been doing on urban
microbes uh for the past five years was
until pretty recently
considered maybe a little bit abstract
possibly a little bit academic the idea
was that we were studying urban microbes
we wanted to understand how they
impacted human health
but most of our research was centered on
the idea that we might be tracking
antimicrobial resistance we might be
tracking kind of subclinical effects we
might be able to explain a little bit
about urban specific diseases
but that a lot of these endpoints a lot
of this research would be
kind of a ways down the line that we
wouldn't be able to right away
understand what was happening
in some kind of disease system just
because we felt that these major disease
systems were uh not too common not to
present anymore
and then of course there was the uh the
coven 19 pandemic
and this really changed the way we were
looking at all of these urban
microbiomes because it sort of radically
altered this notion of microbial
surveillance particularly for the
purposes of public health
and we were fortunate enough to actually
take a bunch of samples
during the pandemic that let us get a
give a
idea get a sense of what would happen to
these urban microbiomes and this is this
unprecedented social change so
what we saw there um
is this sort of
surprising rapid and sustained drop
in microbial diversity uh throughout the
pandemic that we feel is probably
largely driven by people not entering
public spaces as much so what you can
see here is a plot of the microbial
diversity the richness the number of
species
uh in the two busiest stations in new
york city the two busiest subway
stations in new york city over the two
weeks leading up to the initial march
shutdowns in 2020 and what we see in
that time is a pretty steep drop off in
the species richness
during those stations in that time
and if we look at this same trend over
many different cities over a much larger
time period we see
just the same drop we see this big
continuous drop over a fairly long time
period that's happening all over the
world
and this drop is
corresponding with a drop in the
fraction of human rna that we're seeing
in these samples so that's just actual
human shed that we see in these samples
and the uh the
number of human associated microbes that
are in the sample so we see these
big traditions riches drop-offs that we
believe is probably driven by a decrease
in humans a decrease in humans
interacting with public spaces
and
this notion of being able to
use molecular surveillance to understand
something about the disease system is
really what
has then motivated a lot of the work
that bioshock has done in the work that
i'm now doing at bioshock
because we took this idea
of microbial surveillance what you could
do with it and we wanted to apply it to
the idea of detecting variants in star
scope too of course variants have gotten
a lot of attention lately with the rise
of delta but the idea here being that if
you can track the evolution of a
pathogen
you can better react to it make finer
brain public health decisions possibly
create
pharmaceutical interventions in certain
cases
and better understand what's happening
and so those efforts have been pretty
prominent
in a lot of the world now
mostly we think about the u.s simply
because that's where we're based
and these abilities to do sequencing
surveillance has given public health
officials the ability to understand what
strains are present what strains are
emerging it could potentially become
issues
and importantly to identify variants
that are of potential concern to them
variants that are in vaccine targeted
regions like the spike protein variants
that could have potentially
drive increases in infectivity drive
increases in the ability of someone to
catch disease or have a severe reaction
to the disease
so identifying these variants and being
able to map them out geographically is
is
i think really going to be critical to
public health departments both for the
rest of the stars co2 pandemic
as well as into the future dealing with
new
emerging disease with the increase of
globalization increase things like that
so
how this works how this works from
biosha is uh we've worked with twist
bioscience to develop a hybrid capture
to pull down lots and lots of stars co2
dna from a sample or rna excuse me from
a sample perform sequencing on it and
then what bioshock does as part of this
is run it through our custom software
kova dx to identify as many
different variants different pieces of
interest
as possible that we can then provide to
public health
hospitals doctors anyone that's making
sort of health-based decisions
about people we can provide this
information to
and this software uh code dx along with
the twist panel receives an fda
emergency you thought use authorization
for the detection of source code ii
which of course we were we were happy to
see that as well as a lot of research
use only endpoints that we add to it to
assess lineage to assess variance
as well
basically the idea of all this is once
we have our
um stars go to dna that's that's been
enriched rna excuse me
so let's go through rna
from
a sample we can sequence it we can align
it to the stars co2 genome we can pull
out a bunch of different research
endpoints from that
in particular things like the variants
that are found in the genome all the
little indel snips any any kind of
difference between the woohound
reference you know we can find our data
we can list out
we can identify easily for clinicians
for patients for public health
departments what kind of genes those
variants can occur in
and connect them with any clinical
literature that we have available that
shows if a particular variant is
associated with
any certain type of increase in
virulence
increase in infectivity increase in
danger to people
and then we can also place samples
within a lineage
showing where the other similar clades
have been geographically what kind of
emerging clades are there of course now
we're mostly thinking about delta and
how we can identify delta and the
substance of delta in this
and this ability to
place and identify variants has proved
surprisingly important
and persian because it's actually helped
us to identify novel variants already in
new york city so we took as part of the
validation of this sample we took 71
nasopharyngeal swabs taken from people
in new york city
and we were able to detect a set of
conserved mutations in these samples
that were not already known in gsaid and
of course then the nice thing is that we
can automatically put those samples back
up in gsa so they're accessible and
useful to the broader research community
in general and this has allowed us to
better
identify novel genetic variants and
identify
potential new strains
well very potentially new strains at
this point
but to give this information really to
public health officials to clinicians to
any researcher that's interested in this
kind of thing and make it easy for them
to assess where their samples are
what kind of new variants they need to
look out for and what sort of the trend
in their area might be
and
with that i just want to reiterate
what we've done
is build a molecular assay that allows
uh high brain strainotyping and variant
detection in starscope 2.
this has been built by a really
fantastic team here at bioshock of which
i'm lucky to not be a part of and of
course it's been built in partnership
with a lot of different people and
particularly twist bioscience who did
the the wet lab hybrid capture component
of this assay
and with that i'm going to end the talk
here you can enter questions in the in
the chat box here and i will answer them
as we get them thank you very much for
listening to this talk